ja was das jetzt mit der karriere von
michael wendler nach seinen
verschwörungstheorien auf instagram hat
er mächtig ärger mit seinen
vertragspartnern jetzt bei mir ist
unsere show hinter nina kirsch und sie
hat alle details zu dem ärger dem
michael wendler jetzt droht ja hallo
giannina ich habe es gerade angedeutet
es gibt mächtig ärger mit wem und warum
naja es gibt mächtig ärger an vielen
fronten würde ich sagen denn mit dem was
michael wendler darauf instagram gestern
gesagt hat die verschwörungstheorien die
er kund getan kundgetan hat den angriff
auf die bundesregierung und auch den
angriff auf rtl damit hat er sich
natürlich jetzt keine freunde gemacht
und wir haben ja heute schon in der
zeitung auch geschrieben und groß bei
bild.de darüber berichtet dass natürlich
auch vor allem rtl überhaupt nicht
begeistert ist und sich sehr sehr stark
distanziert und haben natürlich noch mal
nach gefasst und wollten wissen was
passiert jetzt mit den verträgen von
michael wendler wie wird es jetzt
weitergehen dass er aus der jury raus
ist es ja schon klar
und da wie gesagt haben noch mal
nachgefragt und wir wollen uns jetzt mal
das gemeinsam das statement angucken was
rtl zu bild gesagt hat und zwar hart rtl
geschäftsführer jörg graf erklärt
michael wendland eigenständig und ohne
rücksprache unseren vertrag gekündigt
und verunglimpft rtl wir werden alle uns
zur verfügung verfügung stehenden
rechtlichen mittel prüfen und
ausschöpfen
ja das klingt nicht gut für den wendler
nina sag uns was hat es jetzt konkret zu
bedeutenden dicke klage gegen den
wendler vonseiten rtl er hat verträge
gebrochen hat offenbar in eigenregie
einfach gesagt ich mach nix mehr mit was
hat das jetzt für konsequenzen im
klartext bedeutet dass rtl will michael
wendler verklagen das ist ganz einfach
sie prüfen jetzt alle juristischen
mittel die sie haben und werden zu sehen
dass sie gegebenenfalls auch chance
ersatz von wendler fordern
das ist natürlich für wendler der
sowieso schon steuerschulden hat eine
summe von 1,2 millionen stand da vor
einigen monaten noch im raum
ganz ganz dicker batzen und man kann
sich eigentlich gar nicht erklären wie
er seine existenz so aufs spiel setzen
kann ja auf den ganzen aspekt wie konnte
es soweit kommen können wir nachher auch
zu sprechen
jetzt wollen wir erst mal versuchen
licht ins dunkel zu bringen über den
ganzen ärger der ihn da droht den rtl
die klage von rtl ist ja bei weitem
nicht der einzige ärger den er jetzt hat
nein das ist nicht der einzige ärger
dena hat ich habe vorhin schon erzählt
dass er einen vertrag mit kaufland
abgeschlossen hat es gab einen großen
werbedeal der werbespot ist gestern
abend gelöscht worden 250.000 euro
sollen dafür geflossen sein
jetzt ist die frage ob kaufland das geld
zurückfordert oder ob kaufland das
überhaupt schon überwiesen hat da wollte
sich kaufland uns gegenüber noch nicht
so richtig äußern weil sie sagen
vertragsdetails sind vertraulich aber
auch kaufland wird rechtliche prüfe
rechtliche schritte gegen michael
wendler prüfen
aber ich kann dir gleich sagen der
rattenschwanz der ist noch viel viel
viel länger denn kaufland und rtl sind
nicht die einzigen die jetzt sagen wir
wollen unser geld zurück
es gibt zum beispiel eine marke uncle
sam das ist eine modemarke mit denen
wurde erst kürzlich die haben erst
kürzlich einen vertrag mit wendler
geschlossen da geht es um 250.000 euro
gage die schon geflossen sind und die
jetzt zurückgefordert werden
mehr nachrichten um breaking news nur
bei bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren